- [Narrator] Have you ever really tried
to learn something
and you just couldn't?
It can make you feel like
you're not so smart, right?
Well, it's not your fault
and it's not your teacher's fault,
it's just our traditional
approach to learning.
We go through a school
and we accumulate gaps.
You're a bit shaky on pre-algebra,
but you move on to algebra anyway.
By the time you get to calculus,
you've got lots of gaps.
If enough gaps build up
you eventually hit a wall.
Calculus makes no sense
and that can be frustrating.
But what if there were a
different way to learn?
That's mastery learning.
Unlike traditional learning
where all students move in lockstep,
with mastery learning
you go at your own pace.
You progress through questions
at just the right level for you.
If you get 50% right the first time
it's not a big deal.
Try as many times as you need.
Get feedback as you learn,
and help when you need it.
Teachers can track your progress,
identify any gaps,
and give you one on one attention.
Decades of research shows,
mastery learning works.
Now you have the tools
to make it possible.
Are you ready to learn anything?